[音楽]
皆さんは
途上国の子どもたちと聞いぺー
どんな姿を
イメージしますか
私が初めてカンボジアを訪れた時子ども
たちが今学歴はキラキラとした笑顔で
出迎えてくれたんです
元気いっぱいに遊ぶ子どもたちは本当に
楽しそうで
私にはとても輝いて見えました
こんな時の子供たちは一体どんな夢を描く
のだろうかと将来の夢を聞いてみたんです
そうすると子どもたちからはあ
1回どんな答えが返ってくると思いますか
薬
9割の子が
学校の先生やお医者さん
または分からないと答えるんです
みなさんの周りにいる子どもたちは何と
答えるでしょうか
きっとたくさんの職業ややりたいことを
話してくれると思います
皆さんも自分の子供の頃のことを思い出し
てみてください
日本の子ども達には
映画やテレビなどたくさんの情報があって
さまざまな夢を描くことができます
でもカンボジアの農村部など
情報が少ない環境に暮らす子どもたちは
身近な大人の存在たらしか夢を描くことが
できないのです
知らない夢は描くことができません
私たち
ワールド theatre project
はそんな子どもたちのために移動映画館で
映画を届けています
私たちのビジョンは生まれ育った環境に
関係なく子どもたちが夢を持ち人生を
切り開ける世界を作ることです
私は大学4名生の卒業間近
この活動にであり関わり始めてから5年
ずっと
カンボジアの農村部など途上国の子供たち
に映画を届けています
発電機と上映機材が持って行っ
学校の広場や教室を即席の映画館に変えて
います
私は映画を届けるこの活動を夢の種まきだ
と思っています
今から4年前
私が初めて現地の移動映画館を見に行った
時の事は今でも忘れることができません
その日のカンボジアの気温は40度を超え
ていてとても暑かったんです
それでも小学1年生から4年生ほどの
子どもたちが映画が始まると聞いて次々に
良質に入っていけました
1つの教室に50人以上の子どもたちが
ぎゅうぎゅうに座り
萌え
バルという
カンボジアの123の合図で映画が始まり
ました
そうすると子供たちはこんなたで映画を見
てくれたんです
子どもたちは身を乗り出して映画が移る
スクリーンに釘付けになって笑ったり歓声
を上げたりしながら
真剣なまなざしで映画を見ているのです
私はこの瞬間に
この活動にでやってよかったと
心から思いました
私たちの活動はある子どもにとってはあ
その日だけの非日常体験で終わってしまう
かもしれません
でもその日見た部屋が子どもたちの可能性
を広げるきっかけになるかもしれません
私は映画には子どもたちに夢を与える力が
あると
信じてやまないのです
このボランティアを続けているとよく友達
には無休なのになんで続けるの
忙しそうなのになんで辞めないのと言われ
たりもします
別に私はこの活動をしていて
未来と褒められたいわけでもなければ
すごいねっと与えられたいわけでもあり
ません
私はたった一つ
あの日見た映画肉 give 気になる
子供たちの夏帆がいい忘れられないのです
ではなぜ私がこの活動に意義を感じ
ボランティアしたいと思ったのだろうかと
考えてみました
まず1つは私の生い立ちに理由があった
ように思います
私は途上国の子供たちに自分の小さな頃の
姿を重ね合わせているのかもしれません
私の実家は宮城県の人口2千人ほどしかい
ない
小さな町の農家を営んでいる一家です
家の周りにはこんな風に田んぼとビニール
ハウスばかりが立ち並び
近くにはコンビニもなければ
最寄りの駅までは車で30分もかかるよう
な田舎です
小さな頃はほんま暮らしが本当に嫌いでし
た
だって同じような日々が流れるだけで何の
変化もないのです
私は田舎の農家育ちという自分の生い立ち
にどこか
負い目を感じていました
夢を持ったって仕方がないかなを外れない
と思っている自分もいました
二つ目に物語の良さを感じていました
そんな何の変化もない田舎町の私に希望を
くれたのは物語でした
幼稚園の頃は母だ内板絵本を読み聞かせて
くれました
絵本のセリフをすべて暗記して寝ぼけて
読み違えてしまう母にそこ違うでしょと
指摘するくらいに絵本が好きでした
小学生の頃にまっ
私を色々間部海に連れて行ってくれる映画
が好きになりました
脳カベ休みがなく
家族で出かけることも少なかった子供の頃
家族みんなでミニグレーがが大好きでした
あって泳動見に行ったその日には
映画の思い出を家族みんなで語り合うこと
ができるのです
お爺ちゃんお婆ちゃ
父と母
兄弟簿人の大家族のわたしにとってこんな
にも家族みんなの心を掴む映画はすごいと
思っていました
皆様にも同じような経験はないでしょうか
そして最後にこの活動がまさに私の理想と
する活動だったんです
私は中学生の頃に
テレビのドキュメンタリー番組で途上国が
ノースを見て
将来は途上国の子どもたちのために何が
できる人になりたいという夢を描くように
なりました
中学生の頃からの夢を実現させるために
大学生のころには学生団体に所属して
インドにボランティア活動にあり
サイドのを村にホームステイしたりもし
ました
実際に途上国の子供たちと触れ合っぺ
より自分の夢を叶えたいと思うようにも
なりました
でもその一方で
自分は子供たちのために何が伝えのだろう
かと考えるようにもなりました
ラックを食べたりワクチンや食料を届ける
活動はもちろん必要です
でも
牛ばかりを届けていても何も変わらないの
ではないかと
もやもやしている自分になりますか
届けられる物資があれば子供たちは明日を
生きられるかもしれない
けれど子どもたちは明日を生きたいと思う
のだろうかと考えていたんです
そんな時に出合ったのがこの映画を届ける
活動でした
場合にはまだ映画を見ることができない
環境に暮らす子どもたちが開くあります
そんな子供たちに映画を届けて色々な世界
に連れて行ってあげることができたなら
そこから夢や希望
生きる目的を感じてくれると確信したん
です
ゴム活動なら子どもたちに
夢や希望を届けることができるとやりがい
をもってボランティアを続けてきました
私たちの活動は8年目を迎え
応援してくださる方々からの支えもあって
これまでに約8番人の子供たちに映画を
届けてきました
このまま一歩ずつ
活動世界に広めていけると思っていました
ところが100面
新型コロナウイルスが広がって
私は最大の壁に打つ借りました
皆さん
子どもたちが映画を見る寒行を想像してみ
てください
子どもたちが a low 見る環境は
まさに水泥
私たちの活動は不要不急だったんです
子どもたちに夢は希望を届けることが
できると思っていた活動が
子どもたちの命を奪ってしまう危険性も
あることを突きつけられました
やむなく現地の移動映画館を休止すること
になり
半年間の球種の後一度開け
上映を行うことができたもののその後もキ
んちの活動をできるの犬期間が長く続き
ました
そんな状況の中内部からはを
このまま活動をやめてしまおうかという
意見も
ていました
そんな時に私の赤間に浮かんできたのが
ある女の子の存在でした
彼女は半兵衛ちゃん
私たちが7年前に映画を届けた女の子で日
呑兵衛ちゃんが7年前に私たちが届けた兵
がについてこんなことを話してくれました
もともとを守りでタヌキに育てられた主人
公が9人の海に入れて新しい世界で夢を
叶えていくというストーリーは
お母さんがいない自分の状況とも重なって
とても共感できるものがありましたと
そして彼女は今
国際機関で働いて困っている人の助けに
なりたいという夢を描いています
私たちが届ける映画はきっかけに過ぎない
のかもしれません
でも私ば
途上国の子供たちには彼女のように夢を
持ち人生を切り開いていってほしいと思う
のです
私は頭に右端できた彼女の存在とともに
この活動を絶対になくしてはならないと
思いました
私たちは現在
ユンジの移動映画館を休止していますが
2022年9月にパワーアップした状態で
退会します
本日私が皆さんにお伝えしたかったことが
あっ
どんな環境にいたとしても
まず
夢を持つことで人生を切り開くことが
できるかもしれないということです
自分の神自分の生まれ育った環境に負い目
を感じていた私の人生
様々な夢を描き
今この活動とで8位
人生の目的を見いだせるようになりました
ちー様田舎町で生まれた私も
途上国で生まれる子どもたちも
叶えたいという夢や希望さえあればどんな
環境からでも這い上がっていくことができ
ます
途上国の女ならず
世界中の子供たちにはたくさんの世界を
疾病
わくわくと夢を見る権利があると思うの
です
[音楽]
映画を届けたその瞬間に
子どもたちに宿るのは
小さな種かもしれません
夢の盾を巻くこの活動が芽吹くのは
10年後20年後かもしれません
それでも私は
営業を届けるこの活動が子どもたちの可能
性を広げるきっかけになると
信じています
ありがとうございました
[拍手]